[Music]
our other top story tonight discussions
about sending students
back to class it was the focus of
tonight's ccsd board of trustees meeting
in a matter of weeks the board could
vote to begin a slow transition
back in july the board decided it wanted
to meet certain requirements to return
one of those was to have a five percent
or less positivity rate
and a downward trend in cases for
fourteen days dr fuhrman lagun with the
southern nevada health district
says those requirements won't be met
anytime soon
but he did say he would support the
board's decision return
if they have a plan that includes
changing capacity and implementing
social distancing
board members made it clear there's no
easy answer
would it be more safe for everybody to
keep schools
closed or at least only
partially open um i don't know i just
feel really uncomfortable with this
whole thing
and it doesn't seem like there's a lot
of answers and i really don't like the
answer of
just reopen because it's not going to
get better this year
other trustees brought up the point that
many other public school districts
around the country remain closed even
with
much lower positivity rates than clark
county many don't plan to reopen for the
remainder of the year
as for csd ccsd a vote on a plan would
include some in-person instruction
should happen at the november 12th
meeting
there is no timeline for a return of the
classroom now it should be noted though
that
two new international medical studies
just released
show no consistent relationship between
in-person k-12 schooling
and the spread of covet and a third
study just released from the u.s shows
no elevated risk to child care workers
who stayed on the job additionally over
99 percent of schools around the country
that opened two months ago
remain open